alors que l'attention de tous et tournée
vers la comédie 19
il ne faut pas oublier la grippe
saisonnière et des devenu ces dernières
années une source d'inquiétude partout
au monde
elle tue de plus en plus au point de
peser sur notre espérance de vie
collective
[Musique]
cet enfant peut espérer vivre plus vieux
que ses parents il en est ainsi pour
chaque génération depuis plus d'un
siècle
en 2019 l'espérance de vie des québécois
atteint 82 8 ans un nouveau record
[Musique]
mais le portrait n'est pas si beau qu'il
en a l'air
[Musique]
c'est ici qu'on comptabilise les morts
et les naissances quand chiffres la
société québécoise
nous sommes dans l'institut de la
statistique du québec frédéric fleury
tailleur est démographe
ça fait dix ans qu'ils calculent
l'espérance de vie des québécois
l'espérance de vie est un des meilleurs
indicateurs de santé qu'elle reconnaisse
et même souvent proposé comme l'un des
meilleurs indicateurs de développement
en 1930
l'espérance de vie des québécois était
de moins de 55 en bout depuis elle croit
d'abord grâce aux gains de la science
sur la mortalité infantile et les
maladies infectieuses et à partir des
années 60 grâce aux avancées contre les
maladies cardiovasculaires et les
cancers
on observait une très forte croissance
et d'année en année on était même étonné
de la croissance de l'espérance de vie
spécialement chez les personnes âgées
mais depuis dix ans cette croissance
ralentit il en est ainsi dans la
majorité des pays développés ce
ralentissement d'espérance de vie qu'on
observe depuis quelques années mais
forcément suscite l'intérêt de la part
des chercheurs qui comme nous allier ce
qu temps d'expliquer ce ralentissement
hop
depuis quelques années le démographe
remarques des pics de mortalité anormaux
lors de certains hivers une observation
qu'il met sur la piste d'une meurtrière
souvent sous-estimée on va probablement
un gros effets négatifs de la grippe la
grippe saisonnière
ça a pris un certain temps avant que la
relève dans la littérature à quel point
la la grippe pouvait peut-être est
impliqué dans le lard tissement actuelle
qu'on observe même le d'éclat dans
certains pays
voici le nombre de décès causés par la
grippe depuis 20 ans il est en
progression
les annie particulièrement mortelles
sont celles où la souche de grippe h3n2
a dominé une souche plus virulente
certaines années la grippe a fauché plus
de mille vies mais ces chiffres
sous-estiment la réalité il n'enregistre
que les cas où la grippe a été déclaré
comme causes du décès on ne meurt qu'une
fois mais on peut décéder de plusieurs
causes le la raison pourquoi peut-être
on a pris un certain temps avant de
pointer plus spécifiquement la grippe
c'est le défi que cela représente de
d'identifier les décès qui ont
réellement été causés par la grippe
et pourtant ces effets sont majeurs
dans les pires années le se répercute
même sur l'espérance de vie des
québécois lui retranchant jusqu'à cinq
mois s'est rendu compte que dans la
plupart des pays européens
on observait un peu le même pas atteint
mais ça fait avec un peu le même effet
ce sur l'espérance de vie par exemple à
l'hiver 2015
sur les 18 pays de l' ocde douze ont
connu une baisse de leur espérance de
vie à cause de la grippe
un changement profond se perd on peine à
repousser les limites de l'espérance de
vie les progrès scientifiques contre le
cancer et les maladies cardiovasculaires
sont de plus en plus modestes
[Musique]
il y à l'émergence de nouvelles menaces
comme les opioïdes et les nouveaux virus
on meurt plus tout à fait des mêmes
causes que nos parents donc c'est un
signal peut-être qu'il faut regarder du
côté d'autres types de maladies et on
assiste peut-être justement une
résurgence de ces maladies infectieuses
et parasitaires frédéric fleury pailleur
vient de publier l'espérance de vie
record des québécois à présent ils
comptent les morts de la coved 19 la
pandémie laissera sans doute une balafre
sur l'espérance de vie mondiale
les luttes pour repousser l'espérance de
vie change de génération en génération
et si on ne baisse pas les bras c'est
qu'on sait que l'humain de vivre vieux
très vieux
[Musique]